if you were having a vaginal delivery
your doctor may perform an episiotomy to
enlarge the vaginal opening during
pregnancy your baby grows inside your
uterus or womb and is nourished by the
placenta when your baby is ready to be
born labor begins during labor your
uterus squeezes or contracts to push
your baby through the open cervix and
into the vagina which expands to allow
your baby to pass through and be born an
episiotomy may be done in an effort to
avoid spontaneous tearing during
delivery if your baby is large or in the
breech position labor is going too
quickly or if instruments such as
forceps or a vacuum extractor are needed
to remove your baby from the birth canal
an episiotomy may be done to help speed
up delivery if your labor is going too
slowly or if you or the baby are in
distress if you have not
already received anesthesia before your
delivery your doctor will inject
medication to numb your vaginal opening
and perineum which is the area
separating the vagina and anus using
surgical scissors your doctor will make
a 1 to 3 inch midline or medial lateral
incision in the perineum a midline
incision extends straight down from the
vagina toward the anus
a medial lateral incision is made on an
angle from the vagina in the direction
of the anus the benefit of the medial
lateral incision is that it is less
likely to tear through to the anus the
downside however is that it can also be
more painful and take longer to heal
once your doctor delivers your baby and
the placenta he or she will close the
episiotomy incision with stitches these
stitches will be absorbed by your body
and do not need to be removed
an episiotomy usually heals without
complications although it may take
several weeks within the first 24 hours
your nurse will likely help you apply
ice packs to the stitches